you can get results from this where you
can't get results from lasers lasers get
bleached out in sunlight I had a
colleague that I was speaking to who
went to Mexico to do crop scanning and
he had a handheld laser scanner and he
had to do it at night in a tent because
the Sun relator scanner and there were
moves about and it was a big problem for
him if you'd have just used a camera you
might have found that you've got to work
harder on your stereo matching but there
are things it will do but laser scanners
can't so there's going to be a time for
one at a time for the other the top tip
for the day is use a stereo pair of
cameras don't get eaten by wolves yeah
that would that would be my advice
we find corresponding points in our left
in my eyes and then we can use that to
work out how far away from us something
is when we have an individual eye on its
own we have some monocular cues some
monocular clues as it were that we can
use to find out depth or at least to
estimate depth but true Freedy only
comes from two eyes in a single eye you
might have something like the object is
bigger than it was before so it's coming
towards us or one object is passing our
view faster than another and that
parallax and that gives us a clue that
it's in front of something else
occlusion is an obvious one if something
actually is in front of something else
we can make some reasoning about that so
our brains will take those monocular
clues cues and do something with them
and work out what's going on but when we
have two eyes then we can do actual 3d
depth perception the classic example is
those magic eye things that were around
in the 90s I'm not very good at seeing
in those I'm kind of cross-eyed and it
kind of works but it's a little bit
backwards but the idea there is that we
trick our eyes into seeing slightly
different images and that gives us a
perception of depth if we've got a
stereo system what we the main thing we
need to know is where our cameras our
brains know where our eyes are because
they've learned it but once here and
once here you know people maybe have
slightly further apart eyes but your
brain will account for this if we're
going to do this mathematically using a
computer we need to know where these
cameras are if you know that we've seen
an object in one view and then we go
into the other view we need to try and
find corresponding points without
knowing where the cameras were your
search space is increased you go look
over the whole image maybe you get
points confused maybe there's a corner
that appears multiple times because it's
like a book and it has four corners and
then you've got to try and resolve which
ones which and some of these features
won't appear in both views because of
occlusion so if you take your left and
right view of my hands you know some of
my left hand is going to be visible from
one I've it isn't in the other eye and
that's a huge problem so what we do is
we start with a process called camera
calibration we have two cameras but a
nearly next to each other and we don't
know exactly what their angles are but
we can find that out by using camera
calibrate
we have to take the picture from both
cameras at the exact same time because
otherwise the scenes going to have
changed so we'll assume we're taking
pictures with the cameras at the same
time something that isn't true of some
visual reconstruction systems we take a
picture of this board and we calibrate
the positions of our cameras and then we
move the cameras and take a picture of
something we're trying to reconstruct in
3d so then we have a situation where we
have one image here on this side or left
left view and we have an image here
which is our right view in our previous
video on matrix we talked about the lens
and Orbis system in front we will do
away with that for now just for
simplicity sake and we'll say these are
pinhole cameras because we're using a
pinhole camera model the optical center
of our camera is somewhere behind this
camera plane so some object in the world
projects its light down here intersects
our image plane and then goes into the
camera origin like this we have an
optical center of our camera and any
light rays coming from this object here
are going to travel down this ray
intersect our image plane and then go
into the optical center of the camera
and this will happen for any points in
our scene that this camera can see we
want to say we've got a point on this
image plane where did it come from and
the crucial problem is but it could have
come from here or it could have come
from here or here or here or anywhere
along this ray and we don't know and
that's what we're trying to find out
that's the depth problem now we also
have an optical sensor for this camera
which is here and rays will be coming
out and intersecting through these
points so if we knew at this point in
this image was this point in this image
then we just project the Rays we find
where they intersect and that's we used
simple triangulation simple maths to
work out how far away that position is
we don't know what point that is because
it's going to change it might not be
visible in this image it's one problem
the search base is quite large reliably
finding the exact same point as this in
a different image when it might have
rotated and change slightly is a lot of
work in two dimensions and you've got to
do that for every single pixel in this
image you've got to find maybe one that
tries to match and here that's a lot of
work to do
so we don't tend to do that we use
something a nice observation called
epipolar geometry to try and make this a
little bit easier if this is our
intersection point x1 and this is some
object
X
way out there and we're trying to find
out how far away it is we need to try
and make our search in this image a
little bit easier so what we do is we
imagine that this is part of a big
triangle coming out so this is one
corner of our triangle this is another
or it could be this this X is somewhere
along here and comes in through this
point so let me get a different pen and
make things easier we can draw a ray
that goes from this optical center to
here and from this optical center to
here to any of these points and they
intersect this image like this and what
this is is our epipolar line so this
line here through these points is all
the possible projections of this ray
into this image so now we've simplified
our problem because we know where these
cameras are we can say where we're
trying to find this position x1 in this
image by knowing but it's going to be
somewhere on here we know it's going to
be in this line here so we've got a
limited set of pixels we have to now
look through so all we need to do is go
for each of these pixels in a list and
say which one of them looks most like
this and then we find it and then we
find our triangulation point and we find
out how far it is away is this because
you already know where the cameras are
yes it's only possible because we know
where the cameras are if we don't then
we have to desert through the whole of
the other image and it takes ages one
edge of our triangle is between the
optical centers of the cameras one is
through this point and out into the
world and the other is some value we
don't know which is going to be along
this line because it's just a flat
triangle cutting through this image
which makes it a lot easier to find out
where these things are what we will do
if we're writing a say reconstruction
algorithm it's for every point in this
image and maybe we will do it backwards
as well for completeness for every point
in this image we will try and find the
point along its particular epipolar line
that best matches it and then of course
you can go much more complicated than
that you can try and find the global
image map between here and here which is
a combination of not only the best
feature matches but also you know it
needs to be nice and smooth objects
don't tend to go back and forth a lot so
you want them to be rounded so you have
to bear that in mind finding a point in
this image based on another one from
this image is called the correspondence
problem and that's really the core
what of what we're solving here finding
the included pixels is hard and they
were approaches based on this where they
not only try and find what we call the
disparity map the the difference between
this X and this X